good morning believe nation today's
message is follow your heart
over to you Shaquille O'Neal what is it
about investment in entrepreneurship
that sort of has bitten you I never look
at it as investments believe it or not
just look at it as partnerships help
changing the world and just being part
of something that's inspiring my
business people on top whenever they
talk about money you guys to my guy I
don't want to hear but if they bring an
idea to me then I think it's going to go
to the next level most of the time if I
follow my heart and everything else will
fall in place I've never ever done a
deal a we got this new company we throw
some pinstripes in the suit you give me
hundred thousand we sell 20 of them we
make I've never done a deal where it was
always based on money I always did my
business deals based on how I felt it
was going to go in the future
I felt it was gonna help and inspire
somebody if you were starting a business
just trying to make money you're going
to lose this is how so many people go
out of business they read the magazine
of the hundred hottest startups to start
this year and they try them and they
fail you lose I don't know how many
times you need to hear this message I
don't know how many times we have
profile different successful people I
think I think this channel we profiled
more successful people than maybe
anybody else maybe any other YouTube
channel maybe any other publication
period maybe if we're not there we're in
the top from athletes to musicians to
entrepreneurs to politicians to
inventors to artists all over the world
people from different countries
different cultures different races
different genders and the single most
consistent thing that everybody says is
you have to follow your heart you have
to have passion for the work that you're
doing I don't know how many times you
need to hear it I don't know that you
know we're making another video on it a
lot of you guys are going to get it a
lot of guys they won't get it hopefully
by hearing it from Shaquille O'Neal this
time and different entrepreneurs
at some point it's going to sink in if
the only reason that you're doing
something is just for that money you
will always live paycheck to paycheck
because there's nothing deeper driving
you forward as soon as you get enough
money to pay your bills you're going to
ease up the throttle and you won't have
any success where if you're driven by
something more than just making money
and making money is important let's go
run the business you got to make money
money provides for a lot of amazing
things it's not that money is evil there
just has to be something above money
something driving you look at whoever
you look up to most what was the most
success in your industry they wanted to
change the way something was done they
had this thing inside them that they had
to get out and they made a lot of money
in the process of doing it but money was
never the number-one goal it never is
and so I hope that by hearing their
message again
for some of you it's going to sink in
and this is going to be the time that
you actually decide to do the thing that
you're passionate about for they don't
want you wasting time I don't want you
just want to be an entrepreneur because
you want the entrepreneur lifestyle once
you do something important it's only
going to come by leaning in heavily on
the thing that you are most passionate
about so the question that today is I'm
curious who is the most successful
person that you look up to that really
exemplifies that characteristic of just
loving what they do important in the
hustle hard work and effort who is that
person for you super curious to find out
leave it down the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to
Michael Brown Michael thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really means a lot to me man
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
so give me the last rocky movie before
creed a final scene was it your way of
saying goodbye to the character goodbye
to that yeah goodbye to everything
combines the best chapters of my life
he's profession life it really was then
along comes this young guy to Oakland
and Wu what Ryan Coogler Ryan Coogler
when director Ryan Coogler first met
with Stallone he was untested as a
feature filmmaker but he had an
intensely personal idea for reviving the
rocky franchise
googlers father had fallen gravely ill a
few years earlier with Ryan by his side
there was only one thing the elder
Kubler wanted to watch the father's very
soulful powerful man and now he's being
reduced to a Sheldon's for himself but
oddly he watches rocky again and again
and he can't his son who loves his
father sitting right beside him he's
watching his father disintegrate before
his very eyes the traumatic impact was
so imprinted on this young man that he
never got over it so he comes to me
because hey look at this great idea you
know revive Rocky I go how and when he
told his stories the distance insane
wrong you're a young kid you haven't
done anything yet but I appreciate the
thought because okay so your own and he
goes out he does a masterpiece Fruitvale
station wins the Cannes Film Festival
every studio wants and what you want to
do Creed the one now either this guy
here is just trying my patience or he's
reminds me of a guy I used to know
oh god hey that was real that forty
years ago yeah it was absolutely then I
realize this is not a movie for him for
his father this is all about a love
letter to his father 90 degree dug down
deep an ask a real rocky fan why he
likes the movies it's usually because
they watch them with someone that they
love which was so great about them as if
they're so partial over people know he
was associated with the family this
young dedicated artist can't help but
reflect on those
who once doubted him they never said I
wasn't talented enough facing like the
industry shake you'll need to be doing
this on a spectral team but at the end
of the day I had to follow my heart is
what I want to be with a passion I
couldn't shake and I be the first now if
I am Paul when you first signed up for
the first one which is back in like 99
2000 and did you think you'd be sitting
here in 2013 talking about number six
no not a chance no screenplay nothing
when I signed on I was just an idea I
was funny because uh I wanted to do it
you know working with my friends because
I'd already worked with these people
before and I like you can't do it my
representatives are tell me you can't do
it no script there's nothing and then
you didn't listen to their advice
alright I got lucky but I just you know
following your heart kind of thing and
it wasn't even about down the road it
was about living in the moment and got
lucky